if there were to be a woman in the White
House how important would that be in
terms of leveling the playing field for
women in this country it depends on what
policies they put in place I mean so all
of the politicians male or female
everything is right now about being
elected but to me it's all about what
actions do they take afterwards Harry
Clinton has said we've got to improved
affordable childcare we've got to
improve maternity leave would that be a
big deal for women if she got into the
White House it would be a big deal for
if any candidates so both on the
Democratic and the Republican side now
there are paid family leave policies
being put forward and that's exactly
what I want to see in the election
because it means afterwards no matter
who gets into office we can do all the
follow up to pull that through so you
saying that the president's gender
doesn't matter I don't think it matters
I think Chancellor Merkel in Germany is
a phenomenal Chancellor and I think she
would be if she was male or female it's
about the positions they take and how
serious they are in those positions for
males or females or children Donald
Trump has said some really insulting
things about women and I wonder if
you're surprised that that kind of
discourse is not only tolerable but is
actually allowed him to become a more
popular candidate the campaign trail is
the campaign trail and it's it has its
ups and downs it has days that surprise
me I think the good thing is though
sometimes when you hear any candidate
say something that is off center or some
semi inflammatory outrageous people are
pushing back very quickly and that's the
power of social media so I don't you
know I'm not going to judge the
candidates I don't talk about in public
who I'm going to vote for but I I'm glad
to see you know people pushing back
let's turn now to public health because
women and children particularly in poor
communities are disproportionately
affected often by disease the Zika virus
is a good example has the international
community being too slow to combat the
Zika virus and should the Gates
Foundation step in and do more I think
we learn from Ebola that we need to step
in very quickly i think the World Health
Organization has done that this time
that work is going on now and it's going
on as rapidly as possible did you feel
that the Pope was stepping into line
behind you
when he said that using contraception
was permissible to stop the spread of
Zika virus I think the Pope was being
pragmatic and I think he's following a
previous Pope that said in a state of
emergency contraception is ok it's a
separate thing from abortion and I
thought it was very admirable with the
Pope said in this particular case and
indicates thank you very much for
talking to Sky News thank you